in his book Mastery Robert Greene
discusses the idea of learning
everything fast not just mastering a
single skill
he believes that it is possible to
acquire multiple skills quickly by
following certain principles
in this video we will explore how to
learn everything fast taking inspiration
from Robert Greene's mastery
1. choose a domain of knowledge
the first step towards learning
everything fast is to choose a domain of
knowledge
it is easier to learn something quickly
when you have a clear Focus
identify the areas that interest you the
most and select one that you would like
to start with
once you have a clear Focus you can
begin the process of learning
two break it down into smaller parts
learning everything fast can be
overwhelming
therefore it is important to break down
the domain of knowledge into smaller
parts
you can do this by dividing the
knowledge into smaller topics and then
breaking each topic down into subtopics
this approach will make it easier for
you to learn and retain information
3. find a mentor
a mentor is someone who has already
mastered the skill you want to learn
having a mentor can be immensely helpful
when you are trying to learn something
quickly
a mentor can guide you offer you tips
and tricks and help you avoid common
mistakes
look for someone who has the expertise
and experience to help you
4. practice regularly
learning everything fast requires
practice and lots of it
dedicate time every day to practice your
new skill
the more you practice the faster you
will learn
make sure to practice the right way with
the guidance of your mentor
regular practice will help you build
muscle memory and develop your abilities
5. seek feedback
feedback is an essential part of the
learning process
seek feedback from your Mentor or other
experts in the field
they can offer you constructive
criticism and help you improve
feedback is also a great way to measure
your progress and identify areas where
you need to focus more
6. Embrace failure
failure is a natural part of the
learning process
don't be afraid to make mistakes as they
are an essential part of The Learning
Experience
use failure as an opportunity to learn
and improve
identify what went wrong and try to
correct it
the more you Embrace failure the faster
you will learn
7. learn from others
learning everything fast does not mean
you have to do it alone
seek out other Learners and experts in
your domain of knowledge
engage with them ask questions and learn
from their experiences
you can also join groups and forums
related to your domain of knowledge to
connect with others
in conclusion learning everything fast
requires dedication practice and the
right mindset
by following the principles outlined
above you can accelerate your learning
and acquire new skills quickly